Hello, Docs. This is Jason Rosen with Dr. Kevin Conner's here to kind of enlighten to our best ability some peeps on
God health a brief background on myself
been
jockeying supplements and
studying you know energy medicine functional medicine getting a genetics because of
Dr. Conner's here and
I got myself a little bachelor's in integrated medicine still studying for my N.D. So
Dr. Conner's a lot deeper richer history. He's been a chiropractor
Been through A4M's cancer programs been through archer Daniels Midlands cancer programs
Works strictly almost with cancer and Lyme patients expert in genetics. I mean, sorry to puffy up kev, but
You know people want to hear that kind of thing and I'm really great to have you here
And to talk about the 101 stuff
The gut. Yeah. Yeah, I think these are gonna be good. I think
There's a lot of
Kind of canned information out there with the gut that could be misleading and could be actually harmful to your patients if
You don't know some of the details
I think a lot of the doctors are like, oh, I don't want to learn all this genetic stuff
It's just like going back to school and I could feel your pain there
Yeah, I'm looking at my pathway planner right now and I'm a little overwhelmed. So
Yeah, it's it's overwhelming and it really is and I understand that a lot of doctors just don't have the time to take to
To really dig into it. So we're gonna try to go through this and and make it easy and you're gonna see a contact
Number at the end of these slides adjacent. I can't see the slide. So you're just gonna walk me through
You can see a contact number for Jason at the end of these slides. He'll gladly help you and you'll see a contact number
For me at the end of these and we'll give it all of our webinars. We're gonna do a whole bunch of webinars
So we'll give you our contact numbers feel free to call either one of us. I think I'm speaking for you. Sorry Jason
But I think it's okay
No, it's okay. Yes, I do. I do so I apologize. They didn't check on
And
Contact us because it is confusing. I understand that and just ask us and we'll gladly help you with all the best
That's what we're here for. We're here to consult doctors
Yep, so we just want people to get better and and you to be the best doctor that you could possibly be
That's what this is all so ultimately to simplify your practice and realize that
Less is more and you know
You've told me since a day I met you back in my PRL days that you're like Jason
You don't need to have so many supplements. You can do so much more with so much less and that's I think why I was so attracted to
Working with you and I think you'd agree
Well, and partly it is for the patient's base basis to because if you recommend too much you know that they just won't do it
Yeah, so I mean you could be the best doctor of the world and you could make the best recommendations in the world
That's patient doesn't do it. What good is it? It helped anybody nothing or or it made them sacrifice
Their entire life to their protocol that they can't even spend time with their family and what good is that to
Right does it help anybody. All right, so let's jump in. Yeah, let's jump into the gut
Well, actually we could even we already know what damage is the gut, but
Yeah, well, I mean my biggest thing that I tell patients is you Geobo's you know
Antibiotic use I mean you can't drink glass of water without probably consuming antibiotics
And so you're always anything without possibly consuming antibiotics. Can you yeah, I mean everybody's got a damage gut
So we don't need to go into the slides of
Got
Disbiosis at all. It's got I mean it's just to give it all your patients have damage guts. I mean period
There's just
That's a given
Well, one of the things that I always enjoyed talking about is
The overuse of glutamine in gut healing products and how it's to me. It's like a
It's almost like you used like a quick fix like allopathic remedy, but the long-term
You know damage could be
Huge especially dealing with something you deal with is which is cancer. Could you touch on that please? So
Yeah, well glutamine is an amino acid, right? So all glutamine. It's very well known that it could really help heal the small intestinal
permeability issues
The problem with glutamine is that glutamine can feed cancer so cancers feed on glucose. Yeah, they do. Yes, you should stop eating sugar
But depending on what genetic defects a person has
The cancer can feed much more on glutamine and methionine than on an elastic acid
So it is
imperative that you doctors who have are treating patients maybe car practically and try to do some nutrition or
That you're pathically and try to do some nutrition if they have a cancer patient you don't ever give
Cancer patients glutamine that should be rule golden rule number one or even like a
One of these thyroid doctors that have learned how to actually palpite the thyroid and they they catch that nodule
They're they're quick to like just put these people on a gut healing protocol and I think that's
Pause for you. Be smart. Cover your own cover your own
You know, you know what and send them out for like a scan and make sure
Because like you said if you gave that patient glutamine and they have that nodule and amine not oven cancers
I mean what could happen in a short period of time if you put them on a high glutamine diet
It's very very dangerous. So it most of the canned products out there the gut healing products out there could take glutamine
Here's here's another side note and I was gonna make a slide presentation of this is so the big thing is
Gap slight diet with both broth well both broth
Contains an enormous amount of glutamine. Yeah
I mean that's why bone broth could be healing to the gut, but bone broth can be a
Gasoline on a cancer. So you do not give your cancer patients bone broth nor do you give them glutamine or do you put them on a diet
That would potentially be a high glutamine diet
Especially if they have some specific genetic defects
So that's what you want to look
Okay, so let's talk about what the genetic defects specific defects to look out for I mean
I mean most of our docs are we don't want to freak them out like thinking every patient they have has cancer
You know obviously the almost people don't
But what are some of the things they can look for if they're running that oats test
To be sure not to give a patient glutamine
Well if they have any there's a lot of different things are the oats tests that you'll want to look for from a from the
Genetic standpoint if you're running at 23 and me genetic tests on people
The ASNS gene is an indication that
The patient's cancer may be fueled off of glutamine
So if they have defects in the ASNS which is one of the most common gene defects with breast cancers some colon cancers
Um some lung cancers
You you want to look for that gene 23 be reads that gene
if they have
Defects in the Keras genes which is the RASP pathway the RASP pathway
Um, they are going to that's a molecular hot-off switch for growth cell growth cell replication
They'll have op-regulated
the glute-1 genes
For glucose transport and it contributes to the warburg effect and
So putting a person on a high glutamine diet that's a tough one because it's have a lot of Keras genes
They have to be at a keto-like diet and a low glutamine diet which are kind of opposing one another
That reminds me of like a CH1 or a CH2 down at patient that needs to be
Yeah, that's kind of a pain
But you got to be specific you can't just I mean I get this all the time with cancer is that you know
Oh, but I got cancer. So what a ketogenic diet
Hold on about here
It could be it could be really bad so you have to know these little
Interracies or you could be hurting the patient or the patient could be hurting themselves
They're choosing a specific protocol. So really important but I love so much about working with you is
Just learning the details. I mean every single patient is so unique and
I mean
We love our muscle testing, but I mean these new genetic testing is it's really kind of level of playing field. I believe in
It's really
Helping us give people more personalized care and letting us know that like you said, there isn't a canned approach to anything
Well, there is a dead and the nice thing about the genetic tested and such is that
You know, you don't have to have 20 years of skilled muscle testing to know what to give the person and then
Are you getting practitioner biases in that testing etc etc
I used to teach kinesiology classes. Yeah, I think you came to a couple of them ever
It's hard to teach a doctor who has been practicing for 20 years to learn another skill like that
That is a high touch high
You know art of
Form it it's skill whereas here's some details about what you could run on a test like a
23 and me test and here's some genes that you could look for that could give you some indications of what
Diet to use so if you could switch slides Jason to that next slide about
Has or the whatever that one
Sorry, it has some of the genetic a little bit ahead of ourselves. Sorry, ladies and gents
Yeah, we know but we are merging the left and the right brain at this point so
That's right
You want to look at some different things that could cause inflammation in the gut and what is gonna be genetics
We'll talk about it the next slide, but this is another one of this slide
About food sensitivity. So, you know, you need to be ready food sensitivity pedals on a person
Because if they have I mean, I mean not to name names, but like
So many people have questions about food antibodies and you are they valid and you know, what's the time of the day and what's the mood of the patient
Oh, what's your opinion on those
Well, I mean the truth is is that so let's let's get back to immunology 101. So if you have antibodies
to
Of anything that's in your gut or anything that could potentially be in your gut
Every time that thing is in your gut your immune system is going to fire a reaction to it
So forever and what I think goes to you, right
Well, every time that thing is in your gut. So so let's say this slide that you have right up here is a who we're going to
Lab the lab. It's obviously everybody who knows syrex will see that that's a syrex test
Um, so this measures foods antibodies that this particular person has
Antibodies to a k-seed has antibodies to weigh protein
Um, and the red ones are higher in the range that they better stay off of all those and I tell people to staff all the red and the yellow
And then they could slowly introduce the yellow back in but they have antibodies to that particular food
So let's use whey protein is this example? So if you're going to consume whey protein
You are going to fire an immune response and what I say fire an immune response that means
You are going to fire a th1 cytokine response your th1 side
Your immediate side of your immune system is going to fire that's the
militant. That's the marine core out to try to kill that thing
and
Whey protein last I checked won't die
So it's just going to cause heavy metal or nor anything on this lift
Yeah, it's not live
So your your your marine core your immune system was only supposed to kill things that is pathogens bacteria viruses
The proteins haven't not been digested have they?
No, so we could talk forever and whey you develop these antibodies to these things but
We don't want to get too deep into that bore everybody death but you did or quorum sensing or any of that cool stuff. Yeah
Exactly, so but the truth is that person has antibodies to those foods
So if they eat those foods they're going to fire an immune response and they're going to cause more inflammation
And they're going to cause more gut damage
So if you have a person and you're going to give them a gut product even one that you or I may recommend
And you don't address heavy metal toxicities that they're got you don't address antibodies to foods that they're eating in their gut
You don't address that they're eating GMO foods you don't address that they're you know
It's anything that's potentially damaging their gut if they continue to do that
It's like drinking poison and then trying to support liver detox pathways at the same time. You're good. It's a losing battle. You're going to
And even more so like the stuff that we will give a patient potentially will further stimulate their immune system and make it worse
Got good could make it even worse. So this is where you got these difficult patients that you do
Quorum quote all the right stuff that the guy at the seminar told you to give them
Um, of course selling their product and and they don't get better
Well, did you address all the things that could cause inflammation
And our damaging that got did you get rid of the things that that are doing the damage?
It's like hitting your head with a hammer and taking Tylenol to take care of the pain
I mean, if you don't stop hitting your head with a hammer, you're not going to
How long is actually not going to work isn't
No, that's not going to work
So you're going to stop the hammer
Yes, so you have to stop the hand that's
airing them. That's right. So looking at causes is super important
Well, that's your problem is easy
These tests can be costly and you got a patient that you know, doesn't want to spend the money to run the test and well
That you know, then you're going to have to make some decisions as as a practitioner to take them off of all the major
possible
Foods that would cause that stiffness problem is very difficult. I mean, are you going to take a person off of cord and egg and
taff and
coffee and oats and way protein and k seed without having a test like that. They're not going to adhere to it
It would never listen to you in a single moment
No, I mean, you have to to be able to show this to them. You have to show it to their personal
You care or they're yeah
Well, it gets even harder if you're dealing with a child that you're dealing with a child of a
couple who are split to know that dad has a mother weekend. It doesn't agree with what the mums
It's to be
It's just crazy. We have
absolute evidence for a problem
That you could potentially fix
But the fix is so difficult that modernized society has made it such that it's
It causes a massive inconvenience on someone to even do it
What it is, but you've got to face the facts that you
The people are addicted to foods. It's it's literally an addiction. We are a society
Did to food. Yeah, and it's it's like okay, okay, then it's
I mean, how do I give up coffee?
How do I dare give up sugar? How do I dare give up this?
Well, maybe that's why I like to only treat cancer and really really sick live patients because
We're gonna we're gonna up the gut here. I apologize, but we're doing well on it. So
Okay, going back to the gut
um
We've obviously addressed ascensitivity some things that need to actually be
absolutely addressed
But we haven't talked about a couple of really important things um
Like what do you think about
sebo and prebiotics
Okay, well go to the next slide once
So this is where you start to get into some deeper things with the person's genes
So will you talk about sebo?
um
You're talking about dysbiosis of
Of the different organisms in that person's gut
Not only they have less organisms that they're supposed to have, but they have an imbalance in the organisms, right?
massive
Which creates
Which creates it in imbalance in the ability for the body to absorb nutrients
and
unhealthy competition
And when you're dealing with like chronic lime the part of the problem with chronic lime and chronic Hpilorae and things that
um
That could cause you know
death to a person
um
These organisms kid actually morph their frequencies
and
morph their DNA
In order to hide and replicate
uh, adorable
uh, adorable flora of your gut so your immune system doesn't even recognize it
And people are now calling it lps and biofilms yet we've known this stuff all along
Yeah
So you have to look at
Track anything that has an lps around it that's you know a certain
Dameter it can't it just it loses the the sense or the signaling
How do we explain that I mean that that it comes down to basic signaling
And the never-forges signaled by something it's the DNA deck or the DNA gene deck and it's just
Yeah, like you said
Complicated and it gets
Difficult to deal with these patients so
You have to reduce any sources of inflammation that are that are present
You have to and so this is another piece of inflammation. So this ABP1 gene that you would look at
Um, that's your scene on the screen right now. This person has no defects in those genes
But these ABP1 genes make the DAO enzyme that break down histamine
That you consume
So you have two genes that break down histamine in your body. So wherever histamine is in a mute
um
cytokine okay, it's made by the mass cells in your body
And it's also consumed
It's in a lot of different foods
But you shouldn't have a problem because you should have gines that look like this person's that ABP1 gene
They have no defects on that gene. They make plenty of
DAO enzymes so they eat some
Nuts that have a lot of histamines or eggs that have a lot of histamines
And they make a lot of DAO enzyme but they break it down and they don't absorb it then they
Discharge it into the toilet
So they don't have an issue with Frankie don't histamines
But if a person so here's another little
caveat here, so I took the person off of I did a syrex test
I took them off of all the foods they need to go off of
And they're straight stayed strict to their diet. I I do eat everything right
But I still have this difficult patient because I can't get the better you have to look at
Other things that could cause inflammation in the gut
So histamine and oxalates are two other things that could cause inflammation in the gut. So
um
This person doesn't have a histamine issue but this person does have an oxalate issue
So oxalates are in a whole bunch of really good foods, right? Yeah
So but you're not supposed to absorb oxalates because you make it enzyme that breaks them down and you dump them into the toilet
So when you don't make that enzyme that can cause inflammation in the gut you could absorb it
You're at a high risk for excretion of the kidneys. That's what causes calcium oxalate crystals or kidney stones in your kidneys
So what a person has a lot of oxalate G defects. They're at a higher risk for gut inflammation. They're at a higher risk for
um
kidney stones
So these are just back to like you said H. Polaria which could morph into
Nanobacteria, which can damage the kidneys and create further calcium
and create those
And not just the kidneys but the heart
Well, the heart is fleeing the pancreas. God, blood sugar is, yeah
We haven't even got into it. We're still in 101. I'm sorry
Yeah, well, we'll have one of H. Polaria ones too here. Yeah, yeah
So dexlide talks about the FUT2 genes if I remember
Um, and the BCMO genes so the BCMO genes are what break down and help you utilize beta carotene
Um, and beta carotene. Well, why do you talk about beta carotene with the gut? Well beta carotene is essential for all
epithelial tissues. So remember for your fetal cell lines your
epithelial cell line is what makes up the lining even got the lining of your arteries
All your organs. So beta carotene is essential for
Heeli the gut
What's that I said means a lot of vitamin C
Yeah, so that's very important. So that's another gene to look at when you look at got health the FUT2 gene
There's a super important gene because this is how you utilize and create butarate for the large intestine
So especially when you have dysbiosis that you touched on earlier
Um, you have to look at butarate issues and the first ability to make butarate. Yep
So the FUT2 genes are super important did I you know, I see a lot of really sick people in my practice and
Almost every one of them have butarate
FUT2 gene defects the most some of these genes that you look at
Obviously is a family of genes that if you don't know how to read genetics if there's a blank behind it
That means you don't have any defect if there's a one you have a sigloleal defect if there's a two you have a double allele defect
The most it's some of these gene families some genes are more weighted than the other in the FUT2 genes
The top three in the bottom three are the most weighted beauty they have the most research on them that they are
The most important of those genes
And like this person has defects on all the top three and all the bottom three. I mean this person
You're definitely gonna have got problems. So
supporting butarate function and
You
You you mentioned Jason prebiotics this FUT2 gene is your prebiotic
Uh, red flag of
Higiotics
This person really needs
What's the other one that you were telling about like mucosal membrane
Gene that like desperately needs like a fiber or a mucosal membrane
Well part of it's the BCMO gene and there's yeah, we could go out and out what genes
I think I didn't put them in any of the other ones in the slide presentation though. We'll let it go. This is um slide one and
Our ultimate goal here is to not promote product but just to tell you guys why um
This wonderful man and I have like decided to discuss things and try to
I guess just make better products or
Well, we developed this product but a year ago. Yeah, probably actually two years ago Kevin
Really time slides. I know. I think I probably put um at almost every one of my cancer patients out of this product
Um, I'd say 99% of my cancer patients because really I developed it. I helped you develop it you you did you it was yeah
But it was I brought a I brought an idea to you and you helped me morph it into
Like something that we wanted to create like you said that wasn't glutamine based that wasn't like a typical approach that
Was canned that was could potentially hurt someone we try to be very careful in the ingredients we put in this that
Regardless and knowing that people are going to go for a canned approach regardless of what they do if they took this product
They weren't potentially gonna hurt themselves are gonna only potentially greatly benefit themselves for many
I get that exact question from a lot of my
Cancer patients will say
Well, I'm on this by my husband has this issue my son is this issue could he take that sunscreen too with the answer is
Everybody could use the sun spectrum
Um, yeah, you don't even have to worry about it
Because the way we designed it is that great you have to decrease inflammation of the gut
So again, if you just take the sun's spectrum and you don't deal with food sensitivities
You don't deal with possible histamine issues. You don't deal with heavy mental toxicities. You don't deal with other dysbiosis issues
It's not gonna be a panacea. It's not going to solve your problem
Right, so you have to deal with all those other issues, but this was specifically designed to help the FUT2 and the BCMO genes
Um, and to decrease inflammation
and to support
the healing of the gut cells
So rather whatever decision you make
And it's only gonna further enhance if you decide it change your lifestyle correct
Absolutely, that's right if you have to work on the lifestyle changes as well
But this is gonna be a big help and there's other gut products out there that wait a second. I have this gut product that has
a licorice, shrew, tin, marshmallow and glutamated all these things it's like okay all those things can be issues
With autoimmune issue autoimmune patients and with cancer patients
So we wanted to make one that was gonna be
fine for autoimmune patients and it's fine for cancer patients and that's what how this got birthed
just completely neutral
And uh
I can't tell you much. I appreciate you helping me
All I all I did ladies and gentlemen has come to this man with an idea
And I'm like but you're being wait two days. I came to you and you said you said we should make a product for the gut
I said this is what I really wanted you said well, let's do it you did all the work and I got the credit
You're giving me the credit for so let's not forget that every idea I bounced off you and I didn't have the science to
To know what to put into it, but at the end
There's a lot of this product more than what we did put into it, but it was
It was something we put a lot of effort into and I hope you guys um feel that and
I mean, what else? Well the other thing all the other thing that we had in mind with this product was that um
Uh, people are taking a probiotic people are trying to take a prebiotic people are trying to take gut healing products
People are trying to take care to inflammatory products and again you get down to the point of
Of the patients taking four things. It'll how much does that cost them? I always look at that too. I mean
I don't write though and my life have an issue with pain for a product
But there is lots of times in my life. I was a missionary and we didn't have two cents to rub together
You know, the cost of a product made a huge difference. So I'm sensitive to people in different areas of their life
The cost of this product is for products wrapped in wood
It's much less expensive for the patient
I totally agree. We put a lot of effort
again like Kevin said
To make one dose last you a day and you know, that's just what we did. So um
We love you docs and we are about to say
Good night to webinar number one. We'll put that last slide out so they think and contact us if they need so and I will put the doctor questions if you guys have questions
um
Um, we need to talk about the answers. What's with it? Oh, sorry. We'll do that
But contact us like talking peeps and I know that's what you guys like so uh
Well, that's what we want these webinars to be and we're gonna open them up to questions as we get better at doing them too
Yes, we will we'll do a Q&A soon. All right. Thanks so much
All right. Did you turn it off already?